maybe there was a reason
i have never
heard a deceased body
pass gas my name is evie vargas and i am
a funeral director and embalmer i have
been in the funeral industry for 10
years and wouldn't have it any other way
today we are going to be looking at dead
body scenes in movies and tv and judge
how realistic they are one
two three
whoa
angel lust
so angel lust is a term that i was not
familiar with until i saw this clip
angel lust is a post-mortem erection
that happens to men that have been
executed by hanging i have never seen
this before
even if angel lust is real
the deceased in the clip does not seem
to be
deceased by hanging i just think it's a
bit disrespectful
it
really wants that shock value from the
audience
i'd love to but i've got a dead body in
the car with me just a glass of wine 15
minutes the dead guy won't mind
do me a favor keep it out of the sun
that is not common practice to leave a
body in a car
in the hearse
anywhere the person that is driving the
deceased is in possession of that body
and is responsible for whatever happens
at this point forward this will
definitely get on the news
and you can ruin your business usually
it's just a regular van there's no
refrigeration
[Applause]
they make these noises the air comes out
it's like
so i have heard that noise but it's not
consistent to how it actually sounds
it's more of like a a growling it's just
air um
passing through the vocal cords it
doesn't last long it will scare you when
it does happen
nate's
imitation is actually accurate to how it
actually sounds in real life
the table that nate is on is a porcelain
embalming table that is where the
embalming process takes place there is
running water constantly running on the
table that drain allows for the water
blood and other fluid to drain
into the sewer what i find to be
unrealistic is that he is not wearing
gloves doesn't have a disposable mask on
or even a shield you have to treat every
decedent as if
they are contagious and use personal
protective equipment i would rate this
scene three out of ten
just because he left the body you don't
do that
holy look at that what he was clean
shaving he's got a [ __ ] beard now it
looks like the deceased is wrapped in
plastic but this also looks
like it can be skin slip where
the skin
slips off of the body the eyes are not
consistent with decomposed body when
someone dies the pressure in their eyes
will
decrease the color of the eye would
become
cloudy oh look at his fingernails it is
a common misconception that
hair and nails continue to grow
skin becomes dehydrated and gives the
illusion that the hair is longer and
that the nails are longer
when in fact it's just the skin
shrinking this
actually looks like the gloving that
happens where the entire
skin of the hand just
peels off
water would accelerate
decomposition and the body doesn't look
like it was submerged in water you would
not
be able to identify the remains it would
be bloated
and it just depends how long the person
was in the water
it can be a strong smell for certain
people they can't handle the smell of
decomposition i use a respirator where
you can barely smell but sometimes it's
so strong that even that it's like
it's very overpowering the deceased in
this clip does not look real at all
i would rate this clip a two out of ten
yes yes i knew it thank you ferdie thank
you
somebody's
experienced rigor mortis he doesn't seem
to be experiencing that rigor mortis is
the stiffening of joints and muscles
within the deceased human body his body
seems to be very pliable what i'm
thinking is just to try to justify this
scene
is
they are unknowingly breaking the rigor
breaking the rigor isn't necessarily
breaking bones or
breaking anything it's just flexing
the arms flexing the legs flexing the
head and loosening it up where you can
move the body in any way that the
embalmer wants
your boss come on let's go
they're moving him so much if he has
contents in his stomach they may come up
5 out of 10 just because he is dead does
not mean he will necessarily lose color
it just depends on his cause of death
and other environmental factors
i do not cut the clothes the family
more than likely wants
those articles of clothing back
the embalmer in this scene is utilizing
wax with a spatula which is consistent
so to fill in that area of missing
tissue you would want to build up that
area with wax and then cosmetize over it
who's mouth
that is an s-curve needle and
wax ligature that
i use in the embalming room
this is exactly how i would do it what
he is about to do is suture the mouth
closed and he
is utilizing
the muscular suture there isn't
necessarily a sound that happens when
you suture the mouth closed so i think
this is just a bit exaggerated
he does tie the
suture in a knot i i do a bow the eyes
and those are eye caps to
make sure that the eye is
set in place it does have ridges on the
top to grip the eyelid you will not be
able to see this
at all you wouldn't even know that
someone has this under their eyelids
sometimes we do put a massage cream
to make sure that the eye does not
dehydrate
i would rate this scene a
8 out of 10. the only inconsistency i
find is the order in which he is closing
the mouth
and putting in the eye caps
so each body would be placed in
a their own body bag i've never seen a
clear body bag the bag would probably be
black
white
it's not a see-through bag at all bodies
are transported from hospitals from
people's homes there needs to be some
discretion there nice legs over here
a great set of guns the way the bodies
are just kind of just laying there and
thrown there
there is a lot more respect and
dignity that goes into placing the
dismembered bodies into the body bags
they definitely would not be piled
in that manner
we take the best boy parts we attach
them to kyle's head
and we build the perfect boyfriend i
find that a lot of movies
want to imitate
liver mortis which is
the purplish bluish reddish color
that the skin turns when
blood pulls to the dependent parts of
the body so when a body is laying down
the blood would pull to the back of the
head leaving that
skin color so a lot of movies like to
show that bluish color to show the
audience that okay this person is dead
and they're like all right we know
that's not the case for every
person that dies though not every person
turns that bluish color reddish color i
would rate this scene a one out of ten
there are cameras
there there's security bodies are not
unattended
then maybe
just maybe there was a reason
i have never
heard a deceased body
pass gas i know that the stomach can
accumulate a lot of gas and will distend
gas can accumulate in the abdomen and it
is relieved
by suctioning out or aspirating
the abdominal and chest cavities once
you aspirate and use the trocar to
alleviate all that gas so it has
somewhere to go i can't say for every
single body that they
accumulate gas in their stomachs
but
some do so i
don't know how long he's been in the
water i would assume several days if
that's true this body is not consistent
with
a person that has been in the water for
several days
it would not be a sight to see a bloated
body would
look several times larger than
its actual size
the features
may look distorted and not be easily
identifiable
you may have skin it just all depends
it's
the temperature of the water how long
you've been in the water how advanced
decomposition did this person drown or
not were they thrown in the water so i
would find that to be unrealistic
the way the body looks
i'm assuming that he has been in the
water for several days and i just don't
find that
it's realistic and it's decomposed
enough to be true i would rate this
scene
a
one out of ten
ah that's very nice
the makeup at this scene is
vibrant it pops it's not necessarily
what families
want
to see when they
are viewing their loved one usually when
a family comes into the funeral home
they provide a photo i try to get as
close to that photo as possible leave my
judgments and my preference out of it
what's this the eyes tend to open up
because
the person does not have the ability to
keep their eyes closed anymore also if
the eyelid dehydrates a bit it can
retract and not come together fully
the makeup
in this scene
is consistent with mortuary makeup i do
have several of these pots at the
funeral home it relies
on the cold skin to blend
unlike
drugstore makeup that relies on the
warmth of the skin to blend evenly i
also use
this palette
it basically has all the colors that you
can mix
you can make it lighter you can make it
darker i'll put a
piece of plastic barrier so that none of
the cosmetics gets on the clothes you
two could have been the king and queen
of the golf club so you could
the talking to be deceased i kind of do
that sometimes when i need help or i'm
struggling with something i'm like come
on help me out here so i feel like
that's very common
i have never seen a person come back to
life last year this 20 year old woman
was pronounced dead by paramedics the
embalmer was
getting ready to embalm
her
and when he unzipped the body bag he saw
that her eyes were open and she was
still breathing i don't think a lot of
people know that as an embalmer we still
have a duty to make sure that the
deceased
is dead
so we check for a pulse check if the
person's breathing and then we go about
the embalming process
[Music]
if i were to cut off a head dust would
not come out of the neck if it was after
embalming and i did this
embalming fluid may come out of the
arteries i never really thought of that
before
a four out of ten
stage of the embalming process
those suspended jars in the room are
gravity injector bottles or flasks
this is
early embalming techniques and can
actually still be used today it just is
a longer process because they depend
on gravity
to inject the fluid throughout the body
inside of the abdomen
is a trocar and that is used today to
suction out liquids from the chest
cavity and the abdominal cavity it is
also used to inject preservative fluid
preservative cavity fluid
the clothing is removed towels are used
to
cover the private areas because we do
have to assess the body and make sure
there
aren't any incisions the body is
examined from head to toe we try to
still
give respect to the body and cover those
areas embalming the deceased where
they died
like this man on his bed is consistent
with
those times i rate this scene
a
9 out of 10. i find the scene to be very
close to early embalming techniques
this is consistent with what i would do
i do the hair
when the deceased is in the casket at
this point the body has been disinfected
has been embalmed she isn't using gloves
and i don't use gloves when i am
styling hair the rubber and the gloves
just it
it doesn't give me
the control over the hair that i want
in movies they always say that they um
look like they're sleeping
she doesn't look like she's sleeping
she looks dead
my goal personally is to make them look
like they are sleeping because that
gives the family
that peace of mind that they are okay
and they don't have to worry about them
died
the casket should be sturdy on the
church truck which is basically a cart
that transports the casket if the body
falls in that manner and
the head moves and kind of grazes
against the pillow or the side of the
casket
the makeup can rub off it would have to
be reapplied so as an embalmer embalmers
can embalm a body to be firm
very firm
or to be more pliable
it just depends on the funeral home
their style how they want to present the
body a casket falling in the manner that
it fell and the way the body moved seems
to be real personally that has never
happened to me
my favorite movie that involves the
funeral industry is my girl i saw the
movie when i was six years old
and
since that age i always knew i wanted to
be a funeral director